le chef de la diplomatie russe sergueï
lavrov a évoqué une série de mesures de
représailles telles que l'interdiction
faite aux représentations diplomatiques
américaines en russie d'embaucher des
russes ou des citoyens d'autres pays que
les etats unis et un renforcement des
restrictions dans les déplacements des
diplomates américains sur le territoire
russe
la russie va restreindre à mettre fin
aux activités sur son territoire des
fondations et ong américaine qui je cite
pratique ouvertement l'ingérence dans
notre vie politique intérieure
le conseil du président russe a
également recommandé à l'ambassadeur
américain john sullivan de retourner à
washington pour consultation je vous
propose d'écouter l'ambassadeur antonoff
poursuit ses consultations
la situation possède de nombreuses
strates et nous avons besoin de
l'examiner en détail
de plus ce qui se passe à washington
n'est pas toujours très clair pour cette
raison aujourd'hui
iouri ouchakov a conseillé à
l'ambassadeur john sullivan de se rendre
dans sa capitale afin d'y mener des
consultations approfondies et sérieuse
en parallèle immédiatement après cette
conférence de presse nous publierons une
déclaration du ministre des affaires
étrangères décrivant toutes les mesures
que nous avons approuvé le président
russe les a approuvés en réponse aux
actions totalement inamicale et dénué de
cause qui ont été annoncées par
washington à l'encontre de la fédération
de russie de nos citoyens individus et
entités ainsi que de notre système
financier
le ministère russe des affaires
étrangères a également publié une
déclaration détaillée concernant les
sanctions et les relations russo
américaines
moscou perçoit de manière positive à
l'aidé d'un sommet byden poutine malgré
une nouvelle volée de sanctions et
contre sanctions entre les deux pays
écoutez bien sûr nous avons entendu les
déclarations du président biden sur son
intérêt pour des relations stables
constructive et prévisible avec la
russie y compris sur l'initiative
d'organiser un sommet russo américain
lorsque cette proposition a été faite
elle a été accueillie positivement et
elle est maintenant examinée en tenant
compte de la situation réelle
washington semble ne pas vouloir
accepter que dans les nouvelles réalités
géopolitiques on ne peut pas dicter ses
conditions de manière unilatérale et que
les scénarios manqué consistant à
exercer une dissuasion contre moscou sur
lesquels les états unis continuent par
imprévoyance de s'appuyer ne peuvent
qu'entraîner une nouvelle dégradation
des relations américano russes
la russie a également publié une liste
de personnalités américaines interdit
d'entrée en russie
parmi eux des membres de
l'administration de biden comme le
directeur du mba est la directrice du
renseignement national américain où la
conseillère du président pour la
politique intérieure et bien d'autres